is your life mediocre 90% of America
gets up in the morning and drives to a
job they hate Deena white please sit
down let's have an honest talk
most people live mediocre lives you wake
up and drive to a job you don't love so
you can work with the team that doesn't
support you and do the tasks that are
beneath your skill level you never
achieve greatness you never accomplish
your dreams you never make a big impact
on the world you're living for the
evenings and weekends and hope that the
time spent working just doesn't suck too
much you may have been told that you're
not good enough you may think that you
don't have the resources to follow your
true passion you may be afraid to try
something new after starting down on one
path and hey you've got mouths to feed
responsibilities to look after and not
enough savings just can't afford to take
a risk the saddest news of all is you've
set the bar so low for yourself and
you've created a world where it's okay
to be mediocre you've created an
environment of thinking small and Dean
insignificant
you wanna do more act more be more but
something is holding you back the people
you hang out with the websites you visit
the media you consume everything in your
environment holds you exactly where you
are it prevents you from taking steps
forward being mediocre has not only
become acceptable but is the norm
because it's comfortable because it's
safe but it's limiting you I want you to
do something important with your life
and stop being mediocre